[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKAEL MEIR: Thanks.
It's good to be here.
And thank you for your time.
I understand typically
experts occupy this stage.
And they've written books.
And they come to share
with you their knowledge.
And I want you to know upfront
I am not an expert in anything.
What I am is a guy who is
an expert in my own failure
and the pain and
suffering that comes
from making wrong choices.
So I'd like to begin by asking
you to reflect on a question.
If you had the opportunity
to make $50 million
in an insider
trading transaction
and you were guaranteed not to
get caught, would you do it?
Ask yourself, what percentage
of the people in this auditorium
would do it?
What percentage of the people
in the organization would do it?
in your family would do it?
For the last seven
years, I've taught
a course, Ethics and Finance,
to MBA students at a university.
And in the second class, we
learn about insider trading.
And I posed that very same
question to my students.
They write yes or no
anonymously on pieces of paper.
I gather up all the papers.
And I calculate the percentages.
So of over a seven-year period
I've been calculating this,
what percentage
of students do you
think would take that trade?
Just shout out.
AUDIENCE: 40.
MIKAEL MEIR: 40?
AUDIENCE: 75.
MIKAEL MEIR: 75?
AUDIENCE: 60?
MIKAEL MEIR: In the ballpark--
67%.
So think about what that means.
67% of postgraduate
business students
going into the field of finance
would commit an illegal act
if the dollars were big
enough and they were
guaranteed not to get caught.
The real question is, why?
Why would they cheat?
Why would they sacrifice
principles for profit?
And the answer
goes to the essence
of what I want to talk
to you about today.
The answer, I believe, is the
very definition of greed--
a voracious, self-centered
wanting for excess beyond what
is necessary and sufficient.
And without an
awareness around greed,
it can be incredibly seductive.
And it can be
brutally destructive.
So I'm going to share my story
and hope to give you a greater
awareness around
greed through that
by telling you about how
through some shortcomings
in my character the seductive
and destructive force of greed
got a stranglehold on me,
brought me to my knees.
And I betrayed the things
that mattered the most to me--
my dignity, my
values, my family.
And how over the course
of the last 14 years,
I rebuilt my character,
reclaimed the things
that mattered most
to me by recognizing
that character is not something
that's black or white.
It's not set in stone.
Character is malleable.
And it's a function of
context and circumstance.
And so what I had to do was
make a hyper-vigilant effort
at cultivating
virtue and character
throughout the last 14 years.
Albert Einstein says there
are three great forces that
rule the world--
stupidity, fear, and greed.
And I'm totally clear that
stupidity, fear, and greed
ruled my life for
the first 40 years.
And then life dropped this
huge boulder on my head.
And I was forced to wake up.
I met some amazing teachers.
And they drilled these
three insights into my head
that I'm going to share with you
through the context of my story
in hope that they
will be useful to you
on your journey in
leadership and life.
Psychologists tell us
that our childhoods create
the conditioning that sets
up the core trajectory
that our lives take and that
typically we have a parent that
sets up the major
patterning around
how we relate to ourselves and
how we relate to the world.
And for me, it was my father.
I remember him in
two dimensions.
One dimension-- he was
a hot-shot surgeon,
drove a Mercedes, wore
really slick clothes.
Another dimension was a guy
that was emotionally shut down,
very critical, very judgmental,
and very hard on me.
So my mind wired up
early on that in order
for me to be safe, I
would have to achieve
and be successful financially.
In order for me to cultivate
the sense of belonging,
I would have to
achieve financially.
My mind wired up that
financial achievement
would define the foundation of
a happy and successful life.
So I got into the
game of business.
I started 12 companies over
the course of my career.
And as I was getting
varying levels
of success under my belt, I was
getting greedier and greedier.
And so I migrated to the
financial services industry.
I set up a merchant bank.
This is 1998.
Our game plan is to fund
early-stage internet
infrastructure companies, work
intensively with management
teams, raise subsequent
rounds of funding,
and get them public at
exponential valuations to where
we had invested.
And I needed somebody to
do technical due diligence.
So I hired a young
guy, cum laude
out of an electrical
engineering school,
tall, blonde hair,
blue eyes, Israeli.
I remember in our first
interview him saying, Michael,
I don't have any interests.
I don't have any hobbies.
I care about one thing.
I want to make as much money as
I can working as hard as I can
as fast as I can.
And I thought to
myself, where have you
been all my life, baby?
I hired him, after
that, made him partner.
We recruited a small research
team, worked 18 hours a day,
seven days a week, didn't see
my wife, didn't see my kids,
totally consumed
with building wealth.
Dot com boom hit.
We get a few of our
companies public.
I go from having nothing
and being worried
about paying my mortgage to
an eight-figure net worth
overnight.
And in my mind, I
thought, I'm 33.
thought, I made it.
I got the Porsche.
I got the Range Rover.
I got the Rolex.
I travel all around the world
first class, best hotels,
best restaurants, really
indulged in pleasure.
And how long do you think
that pleasure lasted?
For me, six months.
Why?
Because my psychology
was rooted in scarcity.
It was rooted in this scarce
competitive adversarial model
of being that I can describe
to you in two words--
not enough.
I don't have enough.
I don't have enough
relative to the next guy.
There's not enough
out there for me.
And ultimately, this lie--
this core belief
that I am not enough.
And so in my mind, I thought,
I got to make more money.
I got to get into
like quarter billion,
half a billion dollars.
And so I thought
that what you do
with this core
belief of not enough
is you fill it up with more.
Does that work?
Can you fill up a core belief
of not enough with more?
Can you solve an
internal problem
with an external solution?
In my mind, I thought I could.
So I moved into--
I set up a retail investment
management company.
And it was a very crowded space.
So we needed a highly
differentiated product.
We set up this product
it was like a bond, where
your principle was guaranteed,
except instead of interest
as you return, we linked
returns to a basket
of heavy-hitter hedge
funds out in New York City.
Because at the time--
this is 2002, 2003--
hedge funds were a very
hot and sexy asset class.
And we designed this product
called the Bank Note Trust.
And we go out into
the marketplace--
and again, 18 hours a
day, seven days a week.
My poor wife, kids
didn't see me.
It was about, how do I
get to that next level?
And this product
started taking off.
We're raising $20 million,
then $40 million a quarter,
then $50, then $100
million a quarter.
And so I needed capital in
order to fund the business
because it's really taking off.
And demand is heavy.
So I started
looking for capital.
And I'm in my office.
And my partner comes
into my office.
And he says, Michael, I'm
about to deploy $200 million.
And I just got off the phone
with our guaranteeing bank.
And they said because we're
buying in such volume,
we can get a 15%
volume discount.
I said, that's fantastic.
Do our investors
get disadvantaged?
He said, no.
They still get exactly
what we promised them.
But because we're
buying wholesale,
we get that beefy margin.
And we looked at each other.
And we said, that's $30
million free dollars
that we didn't anticipate.
At that time, my desire for
money, power, recognition,
prestige completely
overpowered my desire
to live in my moral
compass, to live my values.
To buy wholesale and
sell retail is fine.
You can do it in any business.
You can even do it in the
financial services industry
as long as you disclose.
And we made a
conscious choice not
to disclose because we
thought, if we put this
into our disclosure material,
our investors would find out.
Our competitors would find out.
They'd think we were getting
a free ride off our investors'
back, which we were.
And we wouldn't have been
able to sell as much.
So what we did was we set up
an elaborate offshore structure
to hide what we were doing.
We went to a big, fancy
law firm and bought
a legal opinion that said
everything that we were doing
was legal that we
thought would protect us
and window dress what
was, in effect, a highly
unethical and dishonest move.
And onward we went--
$100 million a quarter,
$150 million a quarter,
$200 million a quarter.
We were raising more money
than banks and mutual funds.
I had a high-power executive
team that reported to me.
I had offices
around the country.
And I was salivating
about this exit at a half
a billion dollars that I
thought we were going to get.
And I was often
intoxicated with the notion
of success and power.
One day, I'm at the
gym, doing my workout.
And I get a call.
And I never got a call.
I always worked out
from 12:00 to 2:00.
Nobody ever called me
I got a call.
I picked up the phone.
It was my partner.
He said, Michael, eight
people from the enforcement
team of the
Securities Commission
just walked into our office.
And they want to speak to us.
I said, what do they want?
He said, I don't know.
Just get over here fast.
The walk from the
gym to my office
was the longest walk of my life.
My stomach is churning.
My heart is pounding.
My mind is catastrophizing.
What if we get charged?
What if this gets in the paper?
What if I lose my company?
I get to the elevator bank.
I ride up the elevator.
I stand outside the boardroom.
I take a deep breath.
I put on my mask of fearless
confidence, and I walk inside.
The head of the enforcement
team says, hello, sir.
We want to understand a little
bit about your operations.
And we'd like to begin by
asking you a few questions.
I said, no problem.
I'd be happy to help.
I'm just going go get
settled in my office.
Everybody OK for coffee, water?
OK.
I'll be right back.
With that, I beeline
into my office.
I pick up my phone.
I call my lawyer.
I say, Mike, eight people from
enforcement just walked in.
And they want to speak to me.
What do I do?
He said, well, you don't
actually have to talk to them.
Remember, we separated the
portfolio management license,
which is under
their jurisdiction,
from the securities distribution
side of the company.
So it's actually
your partner that's
under their jurisdiction.
And it's him that
has to speak to them.
I said, that's fantastic.
Can you send me that in writing?
He said, sure.
So I go back into the boardroom.
I tell everybody that my partner
is going to be helping them.
And I'm around if
they need anything.
And I answer a few
more questions.
And I excuse myself.
And I go out into
the organization
to try and calm the moral
outrage as a result of the fact
that we are getting audited
by the Securities Commission.
About three weeks later, I
get a call from my partner.
He said, Michael, the
Securities Commission
is really uncomfortable
with our structure.
They don't like what they see.
They're putting a cease
trade order on the business.
It's going to go public.
It's going to get in the media.
We're too young to bear
this kind of publicity.
I think we're finished.
I didn't sleep that night,
agitated, tossing and turning.
I get out of bed in the morning.
I go downstairs, open the door.
I pick up the newspapers.
And there it was on the
front page, business section
of both papers--
scandal, commission
moves against Portus,
which was the name of
my company at the time.
And I can barely read it.
It's all fuzzy.
But I see my name in all of it.
And I was like, the media's
turning me into a crook.
And I just threw
the papers down.
And I thought, my
reputation is completely
damaged across the entire
business community.
I eventually had to fire
everybody in the organization.
And I was built with the ability
to withstand a lot of stress
for whatever reason.
But firing good people who
had mortgages in scandal
was almost too much
for me to bear.
I pulled everybody into the
boardroom, conference call
across the country,
gave a farewell speech,
handed out notices
of termination.
I went into my office.
And I broke down, and I cried.
And I hadn't cried since
I was a little boy.
But as human beings,
we're adaptive, right?
So I'm adapting to my new norm.
Securities Commission, so
I got to manage my lawyers.
I got to manage the little
bit of money that I had left.
I got to figure all this out.
I'm in the kitchen,
preparing breakfast.
I'm in a more adaptive place.
I get a call from my partner.
Michael, checkmate.
I said, what do you
mean, "checkmate?"
He said, you know
the $50 million
offshore fund that KPMG froze?
I said, yeah.
He said, I just
convinced the Swiss bank
to release 15 of
the $50 million.
And I wired the money
to an offshore haven.
So now no matter what
happens, we got gunpowder
to fight legal with.
And we got a safety net in
case all hell goes loose.
I'm like, you did what?
I got off the phone with him.
And I'm going to
tell you honestly.
My first reaction to
what he did was relief
because as a result of legal
expenses, living expenses,
and investment losses,
all the money that I made
had evaporated down to nothing.
And I figured, at least
in a worst-case scenario,
if I end up in jail,
I'll have something
to support my wife
and kids with.
And my next thought
was, holy crap.
This was a civil
disclosure issue.
All of the money
and the investments
were in a prime
brokerage account.
Now there's theft.
It's criminal.
And there's money missing.
And I'm a part of this.
And I didn't know what to do.
I didn't know where to turn.
I mean, what do you do?
There's $15 million.
7.5 is yours.
Do you take the $7.5 million?
And now, well, at least,
if I have no money,
I'll be able to fund
a great legal defense.
And if I have to go to jail,
my family will be supported.
Or do you say, no, I
don't touch that money
because that's stolen money.
You don't have the money to fund
a great legal defense, which
increases the probability
of you potentially
going to jail and your wife
and kids not getting supported.
For some people,
it's a no-brainer.
They take the money.
For some people,
it's a no-brainer.
They'd never take the money.
I didn't know.
And to make matters
worse, three weeks later,
we both got charged with
multiple counts of fraud.
So I'm panicking.
I am in a state of
total overwhelm.
I don't know who to talk to.
I don't know where
to go, what to do.
I'm doing intensive
religious study,
asking the big questions.
Is there a god?
Why am I here?
Why did this happen to me?
I'm in intensive therapy,
trying to understand my mind
and how it worked.
I'm reading 10
self-help books a week.
Nothing's helping.
And then I was
introduced to a lady
who I had a conversation with,
kind of like a counselor, who
I thought was incredibly
powerful and clear and wise.
So I decided to go see her.
And I can remember in one of
our few sessions that I went in,
I walked in.
I'm filled with
righteous indignation.
I'm angry at my partner.
I'm angry at the prosecution,
the Commission, KP--
I'm angry at the world.
She sees me.
And she says, OK, listen.
I see you're angry.
Let me ask you a question.
What was your sin?
I said, my sin?
I was playing the
game like guys do.
I was in finance.
I don't think I was
doing anything different
than a lot of people
do in finance.
I didn't do anything wrong.
The world is against me.
She said, really?
She said, what was
your part in this?
I said, I don't know.
She said, it starts with
a G. I still didn't know.
She said, greed.
And when she said
that, I got pissed off
because I didn't want
to take responsibility
that I was a part of creating
all of these things that
happened to me.
I wanted to play victim
and blame everybody else.
But there was a part
of me that was actually
relieved because she
had named what was true.
And now I could see
this character trait
that was so destructive
to me and so many people.
And I could begin to heal it.
And I came to understand
that from my greed,
no amount of money was
ever enough for me.
I always lusted after more
money, more accolades.
From my greed, I didn't
care about my clients.
I didn't care
about my investors.
I cared about myself, my
ego, and my pocketbook.
That's the thump the ego makes.
And from my greed, I was
deceptive and manipulative
and using part of
my investors' money
to finance the growth
of my business.
And she said, this is good.
You're getting
honest with yourself.
I said, it, doesn't feel good.
She said, well, here's
what I want you to do next.
I want you to go
tell some people.
Who do you want me
to tell this to?
Start with your mother.
Tell your wife.
Tell your friends.
Tell your brother.
Tell your sister.
So I went out.
And I said, I was
dishonest in business.
I was playing a big game.
I'm in big trouble.
And I'm scared.
And people asked me often,
did family and friends kind of
shun you after you went
through this whole debacle?
And actually, the
opposite was true.
What I got was love,
understanding, and compassion.
And I think there are
two reasons for that.
The first is, I was blessed with
really great people in my life.
But the second is, I wasn't
arrogant and evasive and vague.
I was vulnerable,
transparent, and honest.
And I learned that
in our vulnerability,
there is just so much
power to connect.
It's a very powerful
leadership trait.
And so I did start
feeling better.
I felt like even though I was
potentially going to jail,
I felt like this 2,000-pound
weight had been taken off
my chest.
So I went in to visit
my counselor again.
And she said, hello, Mikael.
And I said, what are you
calling me Mikael for?
My name is Michael,
Michael Mendelson.
She said, you have
been born anew.
And it was like
the room got quiet
because I realized
that I actually
was a different person than
when I first came in to see her.
And I got emotional around it.
And she said, have
you ever thought
about changing your name?
Because in many traditions
throughout the centuries,
when people want to create a
new trajectory for their lives,
it's actually quite common
to change your name.
It's kind of weird.
But you know what?
I'm getting slaughtered
on Google Search.
It could be a great way for
me to kind of reinvent myself.
She said, don't do it
because you're hiding.
No more hiding.
Do it because it's an
external reflection
of an internal transformation.
And so I listened to her.
And I reflected on that.
And then without
a second's notice,
just like a punch in
between the eyes, she goes,
now how about these criminal
prosecution hearings?
I said, well, what do you mean?
They're kind of ongoing.
She goes, well, look.
You've gotten honest
with yourself.
You've gotten honest with
your friends and family.
Do you want to get
honest with them, too?
I said, what, tell
them that I was greedy,
selfish, and dishonest?
She goes, how about telling them
the situation, the conditions,
what happened, your involvement?
I said, if I do that,
I may end up in jail.
She said, you may end
up in jail anyways.
But at least if
you tell the truth,
you will end up in jail
with your human dignity.
She said, you may end up
physically imprisoned and freer
than you've ever been in your
life, Mikael, having released
yourself from the inner prison.
I'm like, this is heavy, man.
What's on the table here?
I don't know.
I got some resistance.
And I said, well,
what about my partner?
Wouldn't I be
betraying my partner?
And she said,
Mikael, do you really
think your partner has your
best interests at heart?
She said, you can never go
wrong standing in your truth.
And when she said that, it
hit me like a ton of bricks
because I realized
that I had gotten so
caught up in greed and
clever manipulations
that I had completely
lost my way.
And now to connect
with my partner
and be complicit in
this $15 million theft,
I would be a living
betrayal of my values.
And I had three young daughters.
And how can I look these
little girls in the eyes
and be the man I
want to be and say,
you got to be honest in
life in order to be happy,
if I'm conniving in order to
get my piece of the $15 million?
So I made the decision
there and then.
I said, my life
from this point on
has got to be about
truth and honor.
And that choice was a 180-degree
shift for my worldview.
As a boy who couldn't trust
his father, I trusted no one.
Life is a zero-sum
game, kill or be killed,
survival of the fittest.
Always think five steps ahead.
Always be the smartest
guy in the room.
And if you're not, you're
not working hard enough--
identity construct.
And now I'm going
to go into jail.
I lost all my money.
I don't know for how
long I'll be there.
I don't know how my wife and
kids are going to be supported.
And I just had to
surrender all of that.
I had to let go.
And I had to trust.
I had to trust that if
I do the right thing,
the right thing is
going to happen.
I had to trust that life's got
our back, that it's friendly.
I had to trust life.
And that was the first
lesson that I learned--
was to just to let
go and to trust.
And so my next step after
that was to pick up the phone
and call my partner and
ask him to give back
the money so that we could
be honest and work this out.
And unfortunately, he hadn't
had the spiritual transformation
that I had.
And he was like, no effing way.
They destroy my business.
They destroy my reputation.
This is all-- whatever.
So we had this huge--
we had a falling out.
And my next steps
were quite clear.
I called my lawyers.
I said, I want to go sit
down with the prosecution.
And I want to tell
them everything.
Lawyers thought that wasn't
the best idea because they
could use it against me.
And I said, I'm resigning.
As master of my universe,
I ain't doing a good job.
I'm going to go in.
And I'm going to trust that
if I do the right thing,
the right thing will happen.
And after five days of grueling
interviews and three months
of grueling negotiations,
because the dollars were
so big-- we were
in $800 million--
this had gone to the
Department of Justice.
So it had gotten a
little bit political.
And they wanted jail time.
And so I had these
three little girls.
And I wanted to get
on with my life.
And this would have
been a five-year fight.
So I agreed to one
count of fraud,
two years in a federal
prison, with the provision
that I could get out within
six months on good behavior.
The choice to go to
prison was horrendous.
The choice to put
my personal safety
at risk in the face of
violence was horrendous.
The choice to further damage
my reputation was horrendous.
But none of that
was the worst part.
The worst part was the Friday
night before I went in.
My wife and I, telling
my young daughters--
I had one daughter that was 10,
one daughter that was seven,
and one daughter that was four--
that we had to tell
them something.
And then gathering around
the table after dinner
and looking up at me.
They all have these
big, beautiful blue eyes
and long, flowing hair.
What, Daddy?
Are we going to go
to the treat store?
No, my darlings.
I got to tell you
something serious.
Daddy made some mistakes.
And I got to go away for six
months, maybe a little longer.
No, Daddy.
Why?
Me seeing the fear
in their eyes--
because Daddy made
some bad choices.
And whenever we make choices,
there's always consequences.
Well, can we come
visit you, Daddy?
No, my darlings.
You're not going to be able to.
And the look of
terror in their eyes.
And my big one started bawling.
And she grabbed my stomach.
And she goes, no, Daddy.
It's not fair.
You can't go.
And my middle one
grabs my neck and goes,
Daddy, you're going
to miss my birthday.
And my wife's crying.
And they're crying.
And I'm crying.
That was the worst part--
seeing the consequences
of my choices
in the tears of these
little precious girls' eyes.
And as I was getting
ready to go inside,
I amped up my mixed
martial arts practice,
which I had been
doing for four years.
So I amped up my
meditation practice.
So I was physically confident.
And I was calm.
I'm trying to kind of prepare
for mortal combat zone.
And nothing, nothing,
nothing can prepare you
for landing up in prison.
Nothing can prepare
you for waking up
in an orange jumpsuit
in a 10-by-10 jail cell.
Nothing can prepare
you for the violence.
It's not one-on-one fights.
It's five on one, guys
getting beaten to shreds.
And the guards don't
get in the way.
And nothing can prepare
you for the lockdowns
when there's a stabbing
on another range.
And you can't leave your
little cell for three days.
And every second feels
like an eternity.
And a sense of hopelessness
and despair come in.
Nothing can prepare
you for that.
But as I kind of got
through the trauma of it--
the capital T Trauma of it--
a funny thing happened.
I guess because
of all the work I
was doing on myself and my
ego, my ego was disintegrating.
And my heart was opening up.
I looked at these inmates.
And they were mentally
tormented and misdirected.
And I just had so much
compassion for them
because compassion welled up.
And I was like,
how can I help you?
I'll listen to you.
I'll be your psychologist.
I'll help you position
your parole hearing, which
is a marketing exercise.
I go, what can I do?
How can I help?
And it was really interesting,
because my whole life
and the way that I even
went in there was protection
from a place of fear.
My ass.
That's my reputation,
my image, my family.
We're protecting
all of the time.
And that's even the
way I went in there
was mixed martial arts, right?
But then all of my ego
attachments get stripped.
I don't have a house anymore.
I don't have a family.
I don't have anything
except for this heart.
And this heart
was ready to open.
And it did open.
And I was in service.
And being in service to
these people actually
had the days pass
in a fulfilling way.
And I learned the power
of servant leadership
in prison, ironically.
And that was my
second big lesson.
It was the power of being
open-hearted and compassionate
and having the
intention of service.
So we're coming to the end.
So I get out.
Unfortunately, all those
great lessons didn't stick.
And I'm thinking, I'm scared.
And I'm like, OK, how am
I going to rebuild myself?
And I thought, OK, I know
what I'm going to do.
I used to be a hot-shot
finance entrepreneur.
Now I'm going to be
Mr. Transformation.
I'm going to write a book.
I'm going to get on
the speaker circuit.
I'm going to get on "Oprah."
I'm going to show the world the
master of the universe I really
am.
And I still had this
beautiful teacher.
And I walked in to see her to
tell her all my grand plans.
And she said, you are
an arrogant egomaniac.
I said, I know.
I'm working on it.
She said, working on what?
Have you learned anything?
I'm surprised your head
even got through the door.
And I got pissed off at her.
I said, let me
tell you something.
I'm living on fumes.
I got to make a living.
I'm getting slaughtered
on Google Search.
I have got to rebuild
my reputation.
My wife is furious with me.
I've destroyed our
financial future.
She's horrified of whether I'll
be able to provide to my wife
and kids in the future.
And when I can get
my butt out of bed
and I look in the mirror, I
can't stand the guy that I see.
So you tell me, oh wise one.
What should I do?
And she said,
there's one solution
to all of those problems.
I said, great.
Tell me.
What do you think it is?
I don't know.
You want me to go be in
service more to people?
She said, that's good.
But that's not it.
You want me to go apologize and
kind of reconstruct the debt?
That's good, too.
But that's not it.
I said, I don't know.
She said, it starts with an
H. I said, I still don't know.
She said, humility, Mikael.
You must understand
the nature of humility.
It is where all
of your power is.
And when she said that, it
was like every cell in my body
just relaxed because
now I could stop
all of the cleverness
and manipulation trying
to cover up that
sense of inadequacy
that the boy inside
was still feeling.
Now I could stop trying so
hard to be somebody I wasn't.
And I learned that humility
lives on this continuum.
On one side, you have ego
and arrogance and pride.
And on the other side,
you have low self-esteem,
feelings of unworthiness,
feelings of inadequacy,
which we all have
at time to time.
And so I learned that I came
from that insecure, inadequate
place based on my childhood.
And I pulled myself into ego.
I'm going to build a
billion-dollar fund.
Then I went back
into low self-esteem.
Then I could shift myself
back into pride and ego.
And I learned that humility is
this divine middle ground where
we're not better than anybody.
And we're not
worse than anybody.
You've got nothing
to be proud of.
And you've got nothing
to be ashamed of.
Humility is
acceptance of what is.
It is service from a
place of compassion.
Humility is the master key that
unlocks the bondage of ego.
Because if you're not
better than anybody,
and you're not
worse than anybody,
and you've got nothing
to be ashamed of,
and you've got nothing to be
proud of, what do you have?
What's available to you?
Everything, right?
Possibility.
But without that, we often
toggle back and forth
in our own inner prisons.
She went on to tell
me that my problem was
that I look at situations,
circumstances, and events
to use them to fill myself up.
And she said, you got to
flip that on its head.
You need a transformation to a
service-oriented consciousness.
You got to look inside
and say, what do I have?
What are my gifts
and talents that I
can use to be in
service to other people?
She said, what did
you learn in prison?
I said, I learned to serve.
She said, take that
service into your life,
into all of your life.
Give up the desire for the
fancy this and the fancy
that and the house and
the suits and the cars
and the towers of Babel
and just be simple.
Peace and fulfillment
live in simplicity.
Simple, focus, heart--
that is your essence.
Let that essence be your guide.
So I finally started to have
some of that wisdom sink
into my skull.
And as a result of a lot of
hard work and good fortune,
I say through no virtue of my
own, I still have my marriage.
We're going to be celebrating
our 25th anniversary in May.
I try to show up for my kids and
be a loving presence for them.
And one's in university.
One's going to university.
So they seem to be no
high-risk behavior.
They seem to be OK.
In my job, I work with
leaders and leadership teams,
helping, them grow through
challenge and change,
grow through transformation
like I went through
so that they can
be more effective
and fulfilled in
their daily lives.
And I offered to tell
my story to students.
I wanted to go out to students
and tell them so that they
don't make these same mistakes.
And after one guest lecture,
I got hired on faculty
to a major university to
teach ethics and finance
to an MBA program, which
is the prison to professor
in five years.
Miracles, total-- I didn't
architect a recovery
and a career rehabilitation.
All I did was I stayed
steadfast in my practice
to serve with an open heart.
My life unfolded
beautifully and organically
when I redefined success--
redefined success-- as an act of
continuously working on myself
and being in service
to other people.
It's 14 years, and it
seems to have worked.
And I'll tell you,
I still shift back.
I have this alter ego I
call Slick Mickey, where
I want to do deals, want to
make money, all of these things.
But I got to stay mindful
that that's not a scorecard
that I consciously chose.
That is a scorecard
that I adopted
from a society that has
me chasing and grasping
my entire life.
Psychologists call it
"hedonic adaptation,"
or the hedonic treadmill.
We want to get that job,
want to get that salary,
want to get that house,
want to get that spouse.
Whatever it is, we get it.
We adapt, feel empty,
miserable, set the new goal,
adapt, empty, miserable,
on this perpetual cycle
of dissatisfaction.
And that was my story.
I work hard, be successful,
achieve, make money,
then I'll be happy.
That formula for me--
and as far as I see, many
other people-- didn't work.
So there's another way.
I'll leave you with this.
The sum of my experience
has taught me--
first of all, I'm not
saying there's anything
wrong with achievement.
I'm not saying there's
anything wrong with working
hard and having nice things.
What I'm saying is, if we
make that our sole focus--
achievement and
material things--
we set ourselves up to be
vulnerable to those three
great forces that rule the
world-- stupidity, fear,
and greed.
And at best, we feel empty.
We can feel empty at
the end of our lives.
So what I'm saying
is, if we recalibrate
that focus and put some of
our energy and intention
into developing who we are as
a people, cultivating virtues,
and then when we act
from that balanced place,
then we're in a position
to really create
an enduring sense of
value for ourselves,
for our organizations, for our
communities, for our families,
and ultimately for the world.
And so if any of this
resonates with you,
my invitation is to take
a little bit of today
and just reflect.
How focused are
you on achievement?
And how focused are you
on cultivating virtue?
And if it feels
right, maybe you want
to recalibrate a little bit.
And with that, I thank you so
much for giving me your time
and allowing me to come
here and serve you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I'll take any questions.
I'm an open book.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for the talk.
What are your
tactics or strategies
in your day to day when you
feel yourself slipping back
to-- what was it, Slick Mickey?
MIKAEL MEIR: Slick Mickey.
AUDIENCE: Get yourself
back to the middle.
Thank you.
MIKAEL MEIR: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, I would say
it's a practice.
So it's a practice
of deep mindfulness.
It's being really aware of
mental emotional reaction
patterns.
It's being really aware of what
happens in my physical body
and when tension comes up.
And with that awareness,
coming into three deep breaths,
stimulates the
vagus nerve, which
is command central for the
parasympathetic nervous system,
which releases
neurotransmitter--
that's like Valium.
Three deep breaths--
best tool in the world.
And then from those three deep
breaths, refocus awareness
to, what is my purpose?
And where are my real values?
So it's kind of
like, recalibrate.
Get conscious.
Check in with value system.
Make choice, I would say.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much
for sharing your journey.
MIKAEL MEIR: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Initially,
you asked a question.
One of the premises
was, if there was
no chance of getting caught.
I'm not sure how
germane that is.
One sees people doing
things, even when
there's every chance of getting
caught, and they still do it.
I'm thinking of the recent
college admissions scandal
and whatnot.
What's your take on?
MIKAEL MEIR: On the
college admissi--
AUDIENCE: Or just the fact that
people will do these things
even when there seems to be
every chance of getting caught
from the outside perspective.
What leads people to
do things like that?
MIKAEL MEIR: Yeah, yeah.
You know, not to be
overly simplistic,
but I think this kind of
goes to the essence of greed.
And it may not be just greed
for money, but greed for I
want my kids to have
a certain image.
And I'm prepared to cross
ethical boundaries in order
to get that.
And I have such a
sense of entitlement
that I can actually pull this
off that I'm going to do it.
So there's almost like this
delusion that people live in.
They don't acknowledge that,
well, my kid's going to get in.
Maybe they're not going to
be the brightest student.
And maybe they're
going to fail out.
Or even when they
graduate, then what?
And what are the
ramifications of making
them think that they have
a level of capability
that they don't really have?
And what does that do to their
mental health down the line?
So I would say it's
still a derivative
of that voracious, self-centered
wanting without really thinking
about, hey, what are the
consequences of these choices?
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So thanks again for being here.
You mentioned at the
beginning that you
believe character is malleable.
And I agree.
I think that people
can really change.
But there's also
a line somewhere.
And there are things that people
would consider unforgivable.
And it sounds like you were
able to receive forgiveness
from the people closest to you.
But I wonder how you
think about that line
and if there were others
who refused to forgive you
and how you think about that.
MIKAEL MEIR: Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you for that question.
I'll tell you, the
biggest challenge for me
was forgiving myself.
Once I could come into a deeper
place of self-forgiveness--
because we're not talking about
a 2 out of 10 on the stake.
It's like a pretty
serious mistake.
Once I could get to that
self-forgiveness place,
what other people thought
mattered less and less.
When I didn't
forgive myself, there
was some self-loathing in there.
You're such a-- how could you--
all of that stuff.
When other people
didn't forgive me
or had a negative opinion
of me, it really hurt.
It would kind of go to the gut.
But self-forgiveness
is-- it's a journey.
But once I get there
and I understand that--
I'm a human being.
I'm imperfect.
I make mistakes.
I am unconscious, more conscious
than I was in the past.
But I have a certain
level of consciousness.
And I'm on a certain journey.
And everybody else is, too.
So I judge people less.
And I mean, listen.
I've done this talk a few times.
I did it to a whole huge room
of type-A investment bankers.
And people are like,
are you serious?
Are you really going
to walk into that?
And they were actually great.
But there were people that said,
hey, this guy is still a crook.
Yeah, people don't change.
I saw that more
as him projecting
his own issues and his
own sense of guilt on me.
And I just say, you know what?
You can have your opinion,
because I know the truth.
Every day, I made some mistakes.
But you know, look.
We get up in the morning.
We look ourselves in the mirror.
We say, was I the best
husband, son, friend, employee?
It was the best I can be.
That's all we can do.
So thank you for your question.
I appreciate it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So my
question is about if--
how do you see people having
their aha moment if they
don't have a low like you had?
I mean, yours was pretty
impactful in your life.
So if that hadn't
happened to you,
if you hadn't gotten
caught, do you
think you would have eventually
come to this conclusion?
And for people who want to have
this level of enlightenment,
how do they come
to that conclusion
if they don't have a rock
bottom that they hit?
MIKAEL MEIR: Yeah, yeah.
Thank you for that.
Yeah.
Well, hopefully they can
learn from numbskulls like me,
which is why I'll do this
talk anywhere, anytime, don't
have to pay.
I just want to help people so
that they can-- because there
are people that do
have transformation
after I tell the
story, depending
on where they are in their
particular life journey.
My theory-- and this is a
bit of a spiritual theory--
is that life gives us warnings.
And it's up to us to
be sensitive to some
of the nuances.
And I've heard the analogy
that sometimes life will
drop a feather on our shoulder.
And if we don't
acknowledge the feather,
it turns into a pebble,
a rock, a bigger rock.
Apparently I had such a thick
skull, I got the boulder.
But I think that
there are signs.
I think that there are signs.
And I believe that everybody's
got this journey in life.
And there's lessons
that they have to learn.
And in some ways, it's almost
like a flower doesn't blossom
in nature until all of the
conditions surrounding it
are just right.
I think human transformation
works in that same way.
We can water the soil.
We can nurture.
We can do all of these things.
But there's a certain mystery,
as there is in nature.
And until that unfolding
is ready to happen,
it can't happen.
Well, thank you very
much for having me.
[APPLAUSE]